- My mind, is like, thinking way more
faster than I am. (giggling)
- Are you are just talking
all kinds of strange shit?
(electronic music)
- Did I think that I would
actually be sitting here one day
with one of my kids
getting ready to get high?
No!
- I did.
- Pot wasn't really something I did a lot.
That really wasn't my
thing when I was younger.
On occasion here and there,
and then I got cancer.
Started getting treatments that really
made me sick to my stomach.
So I started getting it
directly from the doctor.
And now they have me on cannabis oil
so that's kinda fun too.
I was kinda surprised when
I found out you smoked pot.
Thought it wasn't your thing?
- No it wasn't for a long
time but then, one day it was.
It gives me a lot less,
a lot less problems than, like,
I dunno, getting hammered.
The worst I do when I am high is I'm like,
"Alright, let's watch something on TV."
(funk music)
- I gotta say, it is
kinda weird to be loading
a bong for my mom.
- (giggles)
Are you gonna burn my eyebrows?
- No, I'm not gonna burn your eyebrows.
Start inhaling.
- [Illie] Wee!
- Maybe you could do a little bit more.
- [Illie] Why?
- Metabolism does come into play here.
- What do you mean?
- Like slow metabolism, fast metabolism.
- Mine's slow.
- Right, so it's gonna take a
little bit longer to hit ya.
- Oh.
(giggling)
- What are you doing?
Jesus!
- I just bounced 20 feet ahead of you.
(both giggling)
Now I'm gonna be like RoboCop.
- This is so fucking weird.
- You're just such a good boy!
Just so you know, back in the 90's,
he actually created the first flip phone.
- No, I did not.
- You did.
- No, I didn't!
- You created that first design.
- It was paper.
- I know.
- (giggling)
But you had the vision.
(both laughing)
- What?
- Oh, hell yeah.
As far as I'm concerned,
I can sit here for the
next few hours and just kick back
and watch what else happens.
- At first I was like, this is
weird and it's uncomfortable
and then you're like,
"Oh, this is kinda fun
"and it's hilarious."
- At least I know I'm doing
it in a safe environment.
I'm still struggling
internally though with,
I'm lovin' it and this is so wrong.
- You're a loony bird.
- (laughing)
- I've started not feeling my teeth.
- She doesn't feel her teeth.